alors on va démarrer que la cafetière
s'est pas produit allez c'est parti à
une question tout de suite question
bonjour je m'appelle jo j'ai regardé
votre émission spéciale halloween et
pour la première fois j'ai trouvé que
vous prenez que à thébaux est ce que
vous pouvez pas faire ça plus souvent je
remercie d'être là allez vous plaît pas
la question parce que ça va vous l'avez
entendu dont on a déjà parlé c'est bien
ça me parle et catherine bailly fait que
pour la première fois il avait trouvé
les chroniqueurs beau oui et je
comprends le jo c'était le soir de
halloween
ah oui à la 100ème jour là avec les
costumes d'halloween tout le monde était
bien à son avantage structurel manqué
l'émission un petit aperçu des costumes
vous aviez regardé vous alliez notamment
un roi mage à gauche je sais pas ce
qu'ils faisaient là à côté il ya les
richard clayderman en concert à l'autre
bout ronald mcdonald une maîtresse
dominatrice de clubs et seb est bien
évidemment au milieu huguette de scènes
de ménages
[Rires]
c'est ça votre côté vous aviez à gauche
bernard henri lévy en fin de soirée
à côté un panda qui venait du motion
capture
hélène ségara dans notre dame de paris
et ont super gazole est reconnu jean
pierre castaldi nougat alors syrie je
n'ai pas montré cardin son costume était
un petit peu trop effrayant il était en
smoking comme dracula
ça se voyait pas mais parce que j'ai pas
réussi à mettre mes dons ah ben c'est ce
qui est plus important dans le costume 2
3 qui devrait pas dire mais voilà ce qui
s'est passé quand on lui a dit qu'il
était pas trop dans la thématique de la
soirée qui veut fermer sa gueule
[Applaudissements]
dans ces villes étaient sobres le jour
d'halloween mais hélas et il l'est pas
toujours
il ya des choses que vous voyez à
l'antenne et d'autres qui vous échappe
car avec un ciel les faits pendant les
magnétos alors on en parlait tout à
l'heure le jour de la venue de l'équipe
déposant mon pote qui a dépassé millions
donc on l'a dit et bien il avait eu la
bonne idée de se frapper la tête avec un
palais a oui c'était rigolo une bonne
d'arcade ou une belle plage de fantaisie
comme dirait maxime dziennik
alors ceux qui connaîtraient pas bien le
vocabulaire de syrie elle n'a vous avez
maintenant comprendre par l'image
comment on peut passer très vite de la
dark à al harra sera
[Musique]
on a assez de cette société les mecs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non ça va ça il va manger la grosse je
vous rassure ac ne se fait pas que des
blagues à lui un îlot résidentiel ses
chroniqueurs notamment kelly notre
djette ah oui alors il faut ça que kelly
pendant les pauses semer pieds nus parce
que parce qu'elle a les pieds qui gonfle
ca ce qui lui fait perdre à chaque fois
12 cm c'est non c'est pas pour faire
joli mais sans ses talons on la verrait
pas derrière l'ordinateur
donc pendant les pubs et strain
tranquille sur le plateau et discutent
avec des complices de cyril comme
matthieu delormeau
alors un petit conseil à tous si vous
voulez savoir si cyril vous prépare un
mauvais coup ne le regardais pas écouté
le juste parce que ces mecs le moins
discret que je connaisse
quand il est content nuit il use comme
un petit nadon
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment vous vous demandez ce qui
s'est passé après ouais pour pas que
tout ça n'est servi à rien le plan
maléfique du dindon endroit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
et qu'en pensent les petits suisses mais
du petit suisse voilà rien de grave
ça n'est simple je suis ici c'est
beaucoup mais depuis des années ça que
je me suis calé ya deux semaines j'avais
dévoilé le couvert de jean-michel sur
calogero away est ce que voulais le
revoir un plaisir allez un petit plaisir
allez le cover de jean-michel j'adore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
sa couleur magistrat qui bizarrement n'a
pas été nommé aux nrj music awards à
nous dit pas que c'est pas truqué
parce que c'est quand même le morceau de
la d1 enfin pour jean-michel les en
boucle depuis deux semaines c'est
insupportable surtout quand tu es assis
à côté de lui comme ici vous allez voir
la raffinée géraldine maillet à ce soir
là on recevait olivier marchal
réalisateur et ancien policier ça sur
l'importance pour la sortie du film
carbone
[Musique]
ce niveau
c
[Applaudissements]
direction
ça discrètement dreamnex michel sur
wikipédia à londres il ya une photo de
jean michel juste à côté il ya cette de
benjamin as que jean-michel au moins
quand il fait des reprises il fait sens
l'absence de l'artiste non benjamin est
beaucoup plus détendue
là on recevait nolwenn leroy non et on
écoute et son morceau
j'aime non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est moins bien et moins bien c'est
bien la différence est moins bien lu
c'est un mélomane juste un bel hommage
qu'il a l'oreille musicale ah oui
vraiment oui en revanche gallois n'a pas
entendu sinon c'était direct objets dans
ce pari paraît ce que voulaient voir le
nouveau top alors c'est parti pour une
petite compilation de ces moments
bizarres qui ne se passe que dans touche
pas à mon poste
[Musique]
des poulets tour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
pas pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
[Musique]
je m'avance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas pas dit ferme ta gueule non c'est
fatigant vous chantez pas mal d'entre
vous jean-michel alors tant qu'on est
dans les performances vocales
j'aurais parlé des live qui ouvre nos
émissions puisque à chaque soir à chaque
soir on a la chance de recevoir tous la
nouvelle scène musicale française
pour le plus grand bonheur de jean
michel a suivi parce que c'est un vrai
mais derrière michel non c'est un vrais
mélomanes
alors quand tu reçois evans et marco
j'adore qui reprenait la vallée de dana
c'est du bonbon pour ses oreilles alors
j'ai déjà montré dire des méchancetés
pendant les live mais là vous allez voir
c'est encore pire quand il dit rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mec il a accompli un prince édouard
au pays c'est lorsque vous rejoignez la
grande race track roy a déjà démarré
honorât benjamin castaldi qui est piégé
dans un instant et on ne marque pas lara
sera pour nous tous parce que vous c'est
un bonheur nous c'est une race tracer
les quatre tirs je m'en prends encore
moi oui oui vous enlevez les passions
alors nous avons reçu aussi niño pour
son tube mama site à aller regarder
c'est ce qu'on va voir alors je mets la
photo de ninon carla son importance
parce que jean-michel aussi avait vu
avant le live
du coup vous allez voir ils étaient un
peu perdus
[Musique]
c'est pas possible ça c'est pas possible
dit que le mec est lourd alors passons
maintenant à la chanson alors là j'avoue
que j'ai rarement vu une équipe aussi
dubitative et vieilles 1 personne ne
connaissait le morceau de niño tout le
monde était larguée même si chacun vous
allez voir les exprimer à sa façon
[Rires]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
il était là
[Applaudissements]
le 5 juin
c'est énorme j'aurais vraiment
s'élanceront blague barbeau pas trop
j'adore quand même qu'il y en a marre
franchement non c'est bien mais à part
francis cabrel vous connaissez rien on
aime bien transition mano c'était bien
bas nommé tout théo et manu ce soit
d'autres délires d'un script amano
tennis merci cas merci de suivre merci
bien ça fait une belle transition pour
passer à tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu
voir ou entendre cette semaine et on
commence par une conversation
étonnamment sérieuses entre géraldine et
jean michel qui discutaient de la mort
qu'il souhaiterait
[Musique]
dans ton sommeil
non
aux mouches ont été volés des photos de
personnalités en menaçant les diffuser
de chirurgie esthétique aïe
et donc forcément en france oui moi j'ai
le droit où elle a quitté tôt dans le
petit filet mais d'anim qui ferait comme
tous les bars à chicha jésus vient tout
ce qui s'est passé dans l'émission avoir
façon avec votre oeil qui n'est pas
nôtre qui est beaucoup plus aiguisé et
vous avez l'hybride essence
on chante aussi
à triompher comme si c'était le début de
claude françois de alexandre avec ce
rappel fait et ça harissa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est magnifique les manipuler
demain
[Musique]
voilà
bois attention attention sur ce qu'ils
font avec la mire sur quoi avec ce petit
ton avec al gore que mise premiers fans
eh beh web et s'asseoir demandez lui et
je pense qu'il a aimé l'homme allez
merci bon jean luc lemoine merci voilà
[Applaudissements]